but with that I'd like to invite up
Susan Gibbons who as you've heard me say
is both University librarian and deputy
Proteas of Steven F Gates 68 university
librarian and deputy provost for
scholarly communications and collections
who is going to give a closing remarks
and actually I have a third hat that I'm
wearing today which is that I am the
point person for the Yale Smithsonian
partnership here at Yale and and have
the honor of doing that so what I wanted
to say first is thank you all for for
participating in this for those who have
traveled up from DC and elsewhere we
really appreciate you coming
this has been an experiment for us so
this is we are now into our third almost
fourth year of the Yale Smithsonian
partnership and our question was while
we've had this partnership and certainly
connections have been made are there
other ways that we can really foster
that network and help to push it out and
so the idea was could we take one topic
in this case machine learning and across
you know cultural heritage and bring
that bringing individuals together to
talk about projects that were happening
and then from that hope hopefully create
networks and from those networks maybe
projects that build on it so this is an
experiment of ours to say how can we
keep we have the partnership but we want
to really push on it we really want to
find ways that the partnership can
eventually create many more
collaborations and projects together so
hopefully you'll have found this to be
useful what we're looking for what are
the other topics there are vast numbers
and our institutions are so vast that
it's hard to make those connections so
what we need are other ideas of this
kind of theme that we could then with
that theme
find out who across the two institutions
should be brought together share ideas
and then start a network in that area so
I hope you'll think about that in the
days to come and give us some ideas of
how we might come up with other themes
that really would would have helped to
foster this partnership and move it
forward so I just want to end by saying
a great thanks to Peter Leonard who
served as our wonderful host today and
facilitate
the members of yells a digital
humanities lab who also served as your
hosts the Yale Smithsonian Advisory
Committee as well as Michele Delaney who
is our key point of contact at the
Smithsonian who really helped to figure
out we have someone at Yale who's
interested in this area is there someone
at the Smithsonian and vice-versa and so
she helped with a lot of the matchmaking
that brought all of you together in this
room so to everybody who was involved
today thank you very much we do want
that feedback should we do more of these
what are the themes for them and then I
hope you'll take up Peter's offer to
really keep the dialogue coming in this
particular domain space and continue to
think about potential collaborations and
partnerships so thank you very much and
safe travels to all of you and stay dry
hopefully the storm will will go away
[Applause]
[Music]